welcome back to the rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and we just got a new trailer for
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 coming May
2023 this is the last film from James
Gunn in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and it's the third chapter of the
Guardians of the Galaxy Trilogy it's
gonna break our hearts I'm sure I'm
gonna love it I'm super excited to react
to this trailer and then go through some
of the highlights before in a separate
video I will break it down frame by
frame hey quick reminder this Friday
February 17th it's gonna be the launch
day of our new channel the Deep dive in
which I'll be doing more focused
investigatory analyzes of things like
Loki One Division and everything
everywhere all at once and on Friday
noon Eastern 9 A.M Pacific I'll be doing
a live breakdown of Ant-Man that was
going to Mania you can join me in real
time to talk about that movie so
subscribe at Deep dive INR and you can
support our growing new rockstars
Network by checking out our merch
options at nerdriot.shop like this
Quantum Mania inspired shirt rain
Eternal so let's take a look at this
trailer here we go
okay
it sounds like I'm Star-Lord
this is the
rainbow's coverage has been gone now
Kelly Clarkson
oh wow there's a good Pawn it's always
great fun choices for this my sacred
Mission okay
he didn't want to make things perfect
oh that's his number I want you all to
know that I'm grateful to fight this
side my friends okay bye drags
good night
what does that means we're a family
until we found each other what is that
thing well all fly away together it's
crying a little bit there into the
forever
a beautiful sky I mean it's probably
that gonna be the case that Drax died
but whoever it was that you were
it sounds more like
do not bring me into them
wow oh boy this is gonna be a heavy one
a quick reminder of where we last left
off with the Guardians of the Galaxy we
actually saw them last in the Guardians
holiday special that came out in
December if you haven't seen it I highly
recommend checking it out it explains
how the Guardians have now taken over
the severed Celestial head location of
nowhere they've actually bought it from
The Collector and they turn it into kind
of a refugee for all the different
people who Thanos has displaced from his
conquests nebula now seems to be in
charge of it they've also teamed up with
Cosmo the space dog who we saw in the
first Guardians of the Galaxy it's going
to be voiced by Maria bakalova the
Guardians are still in the crosshairs of
Aisha from Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2
who we last saw in that movie's post
credit scene is just dating someone in a
golden cocoon who will be Adam Warlock
played by Will Poulter in this movie
he's the weapon that Aisha has sent
after the Guardians and since he was
pretty much born yesterday he's gonna
have more of an infantile mind but this
movie's gonna be very rocket Centric
we're gonna learn his origin story looks
like he was a creation of Herbert
Windham the high evolutionary
uchi's character he's considered one of
the big geneticists of Marvel Comics
wanting to create a perfect world but as
Rocket explains in this trailer is
someone who just hated the world as it
was hey we've got a new place to buy the
coolest stuff nerd riot.shop we took our
merch shop gave it a glow up and added a
bunch of cool new clothing and gear
hand-picked by the team at new rockstars
so if you've been obsessing over the
last of us as artists we have make sure
to toss a lost in the darkness tea into
your go bag before the next
post-apocalyptic cross-country road trip
and we have a very stylish line of
quantum media teas hoodies and beanies
featuring cool designs inspired by the
upcoming Marvel film Mt even came up
with one himself Based On Da Vinci's
Vitruvian man but with Kang in there
instead of a naked Italian dude we are
really excited that they are available
ahead of the release of the film so you
can order now and wear them to the
theater on opening night you can
exchange high fives with other members
of the Kang gang in the concession line
to get your hands on those and some very
stylish new rockstars logo designs head
to nerdriot.shop today and keep an eye
out for our upcoming Mandalorian season
3 designs join the riot over at nerd
riot.shop we should quickly talk about
the music in this trailer because James
gonna always writes his songs into his
screenplays he actually had the track
list of this movie played out as he was
writing the script and every song has in
context meaning for the characters both
on a literal level and on a spiritual
level this is Rainbow's since you've
been gone a 1979 song the lyrics go I
get the same old dreams same time every
night fall to the ground and I wake up
so I get out of bed put on my shoes then
in my head thoughts fly back to the
breakup now we're seeing this over
memories of Peter Quill and Gamora in
the history they had remember the Gamora
in this movie is the Gamora from
Avengers end game who has no memories of
her Time with Peter Quill because she
was displaced from the 2014 era of the
timeline when she came to the present
day with Thanos and his forces they've
run back into Gamora in this movie and
it sounds like she's gonna be leading a
group of the ravagers but the other
breakup that this song refers to is the
past history between rocket and Lila
that's the otter looking creature that
rocket spent some time with when they
were both lab experiments of the high
evolutionary we know this movie is going
to be visiting a location that is either
half world but is more likely counter
Earth which is an artificial world
that's created by the high evolutionary
it looks like he's populated this
reality that's set in the 80s with these
animal humanoids now it looks like we're
going to see the high evolutionary in at
least two different eras a modern era
where his head is bald he's got this
interesting headpiece but also a
previous area where he had a more normal
haircut that's probably the era when he
created rocket we see a flashback of
younger rocket and these restraints it's
heartbreaking we see a close-up of the
code 89 p13 that was Rocket's registry
number when he was booked on xandar in
the 2014 film that might actually be his
name whatever he's registered with in
the Nova Corps pretty messed up that the
torture number that was given to him is
a number that follows him around
everywhere it looks like this version of
counter Earth half world is going to be
attacked by Adam Warlock this suburb
gets torn apart as he Zips through it
chasing Gamora carrying an incapacitated
rocket it's interesting in the earlier
trailer for this scene when we see the
Guardians coming off that ship rocket is
not with them so it looks like they're
rescuing rocket from this place we get a
bit more Groot action in this trailer a
reminder that Groot is now in this kind
of swole group Alpha group form we saw
this in the Guardians holiday special
but the idea is that he's kind of in
this jock young adult phase where his
body is growing differently than the
adult group that we saw in the 2014 film
that's because he is that groot's
progeny he's his son he's not the same
group so he's going to have a different
Anatomy I actually had what I think is
an interesting theory that this group's
exposure to half celestials like mantis
and Peter Quill might have given him a
photonic knowledge absorption process
where he's absorbing Celestial light and
that caused him to grow differently
probably last things we're talking about
is this weird little creeper with
four-pointed ears a terrifying mouth who
looks like he could be related to Morris
from shangshi I have no idea what this
is but I assume it's another one of
Herbert windham's lab experiments
something that should not exist who's
had a tortured existence every time he
opens his mouth it's a scream of pain
everything hurts I can't go on breathing
is pain my soul is on fire I know
there's no afterlife just give me that
sweet Slumber so assuming that Drax
isn't going to make it out of this movie
live based off of the various things
Dave Batista has said about this being
like his final movie in the MCU who else
do you think might die in this movie do
you think rocket will make it out alive
do you think this movie will spare Lyla
but then kill her off by the end of it
comment down below with what you think
will be the most heartbreaking moment of
this film and a reminder to subscribe to
the deep dive launching this Friday
we're gonna go live with five premium
videos that you're gonna love including
the quantumania live stream we're gonna
dig into all the spoilers of it so
beware for that you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at eavos you can
follow new rockstars you can subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]